so help me god congratulations mr
president
minutes after joe biden was sworn in as
us president last week
israel's prime minister released a
congratulatory video
referencing a warm personal friendship
and also his government's immediate
priority
for the new administration and to
confront common challenges
chief among them the threat posed by
iran on tuesday israel's top general
turned up the volume saying he was
preparing
new attack plans targeting iran
i have instructed the idf to prepare
several operational plans
in addition to existing ones which we
will develop throughout the coming year
the power to initiate them lies with the
political echelon
however the offensive options need to be
prepared ready and
on the table the general warned the new
us administration that returning to the
iran nuclear deal from which donald
trump withdrew in 2018
would be a mistake that would allow iran
to develop a nuclear weapon
even if there's a similar agreement with
a few improvements
it is operationally and strategically
wrong
it's operationally wrong because it will
again allow at its end or even
beforehand
iran to enrich uranium to develop
centrifuges
to develop even the capabilities of the
weapons
until developing a bomb the message was
delivered on the same day that joe
biden's pick for secretary of state
was confirmed by the u.s senate last
week anthony blinken
signaled that the u.s was not preparing
to rush back into the deal
and would consult with israel and other
regional allies on its policy
for its part iran says time is short for
the u.s to revive the deal
known as the joint comprehensive plan of
action or jcpoa
any progress in these regards is totally
dependent on the practical steps the u.s
should take to meet its obligations
under the resolution 2231. actually
america's time is limited and the window
of opportunity for the u.s and the
european members
of the gcpoa remains open for a limited
period
iran is still reeling from a series of
blows inflicted during the last year of
the trump administration
including the u.s assassination of its
most revered military figure
qasim solemani and the killing of its
chief nuclear scientist mussin
fakhrizadeh
which tehran attributes to israel
for israel the shift away from trump's
hard line on iran
is a major foreign policy challenge
provoking a debate about whether the
government should confront the biden
administration publicly
or lobby behind the scenes in this
instance
the public confrontation has come from
the head of its army
harry fawcett al jazeera west jerusalem